hello everyone and welcome back to the
speed
cheers championship uh we are in the
other semi-final match magnus carlson vs
uh maxime bashar lagrave we already
checked out the match wasteless overs
hikaru nakamura
uh he car won that match and now he
waits for the winner of this one to see
who meets him
in the finals so i decided to show this
um game while the match is still being
played uh it's
very very intense i'm not going to spoil
anything for you but
just going to mention that this is a
game from the bullet section
so not a real bullet it's a one plus a
one plus one
one minute per player and you get a one
second increment for every move you make
so
uh let's see what happens here uh magnus
with the white piece
so he opens with d4 sorry about that uh
and the maxim goes for
knight to f6 and whenever we see this
someone goes d4
maximum goes knight to f6 uh we are uh
pretty sure that we're going to see a
groomfield on the board so c4
g6 knight to c3 and d5 the groomful
defense
is on the board knight to f3 by magnus
and now
bishop to g7 and now comes captures on
d5 captures on d5 and queen to a for
check a very very uh old line but there
are
there are some games in 2020 that i have
been played
this way so nice to see six defending
and only now e4 charging this knight and
while you can capture it's better to go
knight to b6 to challenge white's queen
queen back to c2 and only now e6 it's
very interesting because you actually
can capture on d4
but maxine probably uh has his
suspicions that magnus is
very well versed in this opening so he
decides to mix it up with e6
and he says i'm i might capture on the
next movie if you don't defend it
and uh of course it is as of move eight
that we have a completely new game so
magnus defense the pawn bishop to e3
not really it's not all that uh greatly
defended but
uh for example if you go after at knight
captures here then just bishop captures
and after bishop captures and knight
captures uh
it's not going to be all that great
because just queen captures on d4
and well it's much better for black but
if you go for something like for example
uh knight captures and e4 and now after
knight captures or bishop captures for
that matter batteries bishop captures
bishop captures and now knight to b5
then
it could be very problematic for black
because the bishop is now attacked twice
also knight characters on c7 is being
threatened the queen and knight are both
attacking that c7 square
so uh not the greatest so black of
course doesn't go for any
pawn grabbing action here he just
castles and now
rook to d1 uh now the pawn is
sufficiently defended
bishop to d7 and now magnus goes for h4
he wants to
bust open the position with h5 and uh
capture on g6
we have h6 by maxine and now e5
uh we have knights the e7 by playing e5
magnus lost control of the f5 square
so uh maxime immediately transfers the
knight to e7
and in the future he wants to get it to
f5 we have h5 by magnus
and knight to f5 as planned and here
that magnus captures and g6 captures
captures and now
bishop to d3 and here we have a very
interesting
idea by mcc knight captures an e3 f
captures and
bishop to c6 now giving up the g6 pawn
uh to mess up carlsen's uh well
everything here
on the king's side and magnus goes for
bishop captures in g6
we have bishop captures on f3 g captures
and
rook captures and now king the e2 uh
getting the rook into the game
which tempo as the rook on f3 is under
attack so here
maxim goes rook to g3 a very interesting
attempt is rook captures on e3 we're
just going to briefly show it
after king captures queen g5 check and
now uh the king has to go to d3 and
allow queen captures because if you go
somewhere down the board just queen g2
check and you have to go back if you go
further down the board then you might
even lose a rook
so here best is king d3 you allow the
capture on g6 and now you go knight to
e4 and next you're gonna play
uh you're gonna bring your other rook to
g1 you're gonna play knight to f6
check and so on and have a most likely a
winning position
so instead after king e2 we have rook to
g3 by magnus and
now comes rook d sorry by maxine and
rook d to g1 by magnus
queen to g5 threatening to win material
here and now magnus trades once captures
captures and now
bishop to h7 so the bishop on g6 is not
a target forever we have king to h8 and
now magnus needs to decide what to do
and the best
here is queen to g6 you force a queen
trait here
uh and after captures and captures you
just enjoy this
uh well end game the knight can come to
e4 uh later on it can come to f6
uh so it's a very it's a very good
position for white
so instead after king to h8 magnus
played bishop back to e4
but now comes rook to f8 maxi mobilizes
the rest of his pieces king to d3 and
now
c5 of course the king is in the center
of the board so you want to
bust open the position knights the e2
attacking maxime's queen here
and now c4 with check we have king to d2
and now rook to f2 not allowing the
queen to capture the knight is now
pinned
and here we have rook to f1 magnus now
offers a rook because if rook captures
then the knight is no longer pinned
magnus would win the queen so here
instead we have h5 by maxine he starts
pushing his pass pawn and he wants to
make another queen
so magnus goes rook captures with queen
captures and now he grabs a pawn
bishop captures on b7 but this is uh
well one pawn that could be one pawn too
many because
bishop to h6 now with the threat on the
e3 pawn
magnus defends it queen to e4 but now
comes a
a beautiful move by maxine uh feel free
to pause the video and
win this game for black while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it and i know all of you were able to
do it so congratulations to everyone
uh and let's just all enjoy the show uh
it's
c3 with check the the point is you want
to free up the c4 square with
check uh so without losing time and the
magnus needs to decide what to do here
if you capture with the king then the
king no longer defends the knight so
that's out of the question
magnus captured with the pawn but now
comes knight to c for
wit check and this is where it gets
really interesting king to d3
and now knight to b2 with check magnus
just go it went back king to d2
and now comes bishop captures an e3
check and
he was in this position that magnus
carlsen resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
you remove the king
now you cannot go to d1 the knight
covers that uh and then you lose the
knight and everything is nicely defended
uh so you're just down a piece in a
completely lost position
or even better after bishop captures you
actually capture it with the queen
but now knight the c for check and white
again
loses the queen so nothing to do here
after bishop captures on e3
magnus resigned and a brilliant victory
for maxine vashir lagrav
in the grunfeld defense
so yeah that's it uh for this video i do
hope you guys enjoyed it a very short
one but like i said it's a bullet game
so we're not going to over analyze it
uh i hope you don't mind i would like to
thank mister hoodie guy obrad mishkovic
jacob laurie and sam and colin
mclaughlin for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
and as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this clash with a game or
two
not spoiling any results checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
and then we go back to the morphe saga
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day